[Applause]
it's me Greg I'm on vacation this week
this is me surfing and Here I am scuba
diving and this is me in a local jail
right before they strip-searched me in
all honesty I asked for it I mean
seriously I asked me to do it it's true
I am actually on vacation right now we
tape this show last Friday
now something could happen between then
and now that changes everything which is
why I pick stories for this show with no
inherent news value I'm being honest
except for this one today I found out
that they've stopped the Jerry Springer
Show and it made me think Jerry Springer
is still on but also why stop his show
now well you might say who needs it
right now after all with a nation's
political tension every day is the Jerry
Springer Show full of hair pulling chair
throwing name-calling all because we
have opposing views and the media blames
of course the guy in the White House who
I call the orange Gandhi which is BS
politics always causes friction we just
have more places to see it 24-hour cable
news social media Lou Dobbs is hot tub
we get it the country is divided but
that's actually good it's better to have
two sides than one and I wish we had
more sides actually plus we just
celebrated our 240 second birthday we've
been through way worse than this
and by the way we look pretty awesome
for our age take a look at this map we
haven't gained a pound in 60 years
Idaho as abs but there's always room for
improvement the good news is most of
America isn't what's on TV the shouting
on camera is what attracts the camera in
the first place so that's why you see
more of it however it may not be a bad
idea to lighten up a little which is why
I'm still calling for it keep the peace
movement to start we got to admit that
everyone who annoys you thinks that
they're right but so do you and that
annoys them so the solution is that we
should admit that we see things through
different filters like this week a
neighbor posted something about Trump I
didn't agree with it and I replied the
next thing you know things got really
really personal
now I'm not proud of what I did on his
porch it wasn't supposed to be that
messy
I do eat a lot of fiber and now I'm
worried you might have a surveillance
camera but worse I'll bet I didn't
convince him and he didn't convince me
and that's fine we're both good people
who see things differently but if birds
and cats can get along why can't we we
cut off that tape before the ugliness
but that's why I'm for a peace movement
a conservative peace movement like
hippies that smell good
the next time you're in a debate I ask
you stay polite compromise and forgive
when a line is crossed you may not get
anything in return still all you can do
is take the high ground and see if they
follow if that doesn't work date one of
their relatives it drives them nuts
[Applause]
look at that
let's welcome tonight's guests
aside from Betty Crocker he's my
favorite Baker former CIA operative
diligence president all-around handsome
dude Mike Baker he could turn the world
on with his smile and turn it off with
his odor sorry Fox News radio host Tom
shaloo her favorite food is corn on the
McCobb that is a great intro National
Review reporter cat Tim and he jumps
rope with a telephone line former WWE
Superstar and my massive sidekick Tyrus
all right my good to see is there any
hope for the United States to actually
become United No
by the way I like to wait this is the
international symbol for jumping rope
right Cyrus yeah yeah I wasn't even
listening to the question you know what
but I think you've got an absolutely
perfect point here there's nobody lives
in the center anymore nobody is living
in the middle ground it's like trench
warfare where both people are both sides
are over here on opposite sides throwing
hand grenades at each other and we've
lost the ability to have a civil
discourse really about just about
anything you you as soon as you start
talking somehow it veers off course and
I've seen I've got family that sits on
both sides of the spectrum right right
and left and and and on the left it's
pretty hardcore left and I just want
have dinner right you just want to get
together and enjoy family and everything
and you can't you can't do it it's a
very very difficult I we're not
approaching civil war status I only got
so ever gonna happen and by the way if
it did the Left would get its ass kicked
I think we do need to step back take a
breath and do exactly what you say next
time you're in a conversation just
realize okay look we've seen a lot worse
times and it's not the death or the
Republic every time the administration
takes an action mm-hmm you know tom is
it too much to expect the left to meet
the right like halfway not even halfway
I'd be happy if 10% if because they're
angry they're out of power would they
actually respond which tell you want 10%
or you're gonna give 10 or you're gonna
give 90 I'm gonna give 90 oh that's too
much I don't know I don't think it's
that bad I mean people yell at each
other on in the media that's true on TV
we yell at each other we're always
yelling at each other yeah but and
Twitter and everything else but in
normal life we're kind of nice to each
other most of the time you know unless
they kick you out of a restaurant every
once in a while yes but I don't mind I
mean I think maybe the civility thing as
I don't like civility it's like at the
debates they're always it's like fake
disabilities fake this German wants to
be nice they're like you know they ask
you a question at a debate
well first I'd like to pause and thank
everyone for being here it's like shut
up and answer the question yes I want to
be a little more rude shut up Tom yeah
yes alright Tom brought up social media
do you but I have a theory and I'm not
sure it's like does it contribute to
hostilities or is it a release valve so
the hostilities are less likely to be on
the street and more likely in the
broadband where nobody really gets hurt
is that correct or you just like staring
at me blankly I mean waiting for me to
shut up I mean I think that people can
get hurt on social media I think that
sometimes people can be really really
mean and really really nasty and
whenever you look at their BIOS it's
always like loving grandfather whoa why
are you being why are you like this
where does this come from is it better
that he's not yelling at his grandkids I
guess probably yes I want everyone to be
nice to their grandkids so I'll be fine
being called an idiot bimbo by a grandpa
yes you know I can I can take it but
yeah I think social media though it
shows you how really ugly people some
people are on the inside and I think
it's actually kind of terrifying tyrus
what no you said my name I know that's
how I try to get you interested in this
show should should we all take the high
road in political debates instead of
trying to scare Yahoo I thought you
asked me this question a week ago I take
the high road visit ah listen I told the
middle I walk casually I'm not much of a
Yeller so yeah people scream and stuff
I'm using more than what I'm a facial
guy so the social media doesn't do much
for me but I do agree that social media
is good for some people to say what they
would never say in person in real life
because the ramifications and
repercussions for some of their tough
talk or their their negative talk worst
thing happens to them they get blocked
right you walk up to me on the street
and say some of things to meet you get
you ass kicked
then you got a heel you got you know get
new teeth probably in some cases learn
to walk again so I mean it's it's less
people are a lot tougher without the
consequences but what works for me
because I get a lot of questions asked I
tend to answer them in ways that ends
the conversation
hey Cyrus how you doing maintaining keep
what's going on room temperature just
throw something madam hey what's up
furnace and by the time they figure out
what you said you're gone yeah but I do
think that there's there's a potentially
dangerous numbing effect right from the
social media and much like kids playing
shooter games non-stop right and the
ability for that to stunt sort of the
development of empathy and those kids I
think the social media can do the same
thing and we don't know because it
hasn't been here long enough what the
long-term impact can be but I worry that
it's it's removed the ability for us to
have a reasoned conversation yeah he's
in the current moment well I'd like to
ask my dad to stop yelling a cat Tim no
but it is true that like you're missing
the fit like in order to have a
conversation you have to have some kind
of facial recognition to see the eyes
and know if somebody's kidding like 90%
of all the problems on the social media
are because nobody knows when you're
kidding you know or like I get huge
fights on texts from just people because
they read it wrong I mean I do say
majest they believe that stuff gonna
make him work late no way that's a big
problem in relationships yes because yes
we think facts and they write emotion
like what time you got to be home and
when I read it what time you gonna be
home she's like you were on the set for
12 hours everything okay um why he
always chick then when she calls I'm
like what yes
I'm not doing nothing I'm trying to work
why you young you yelled at me first
when you text me but but when they ever
run us now when someone texts she's like
I heard what you said you know you
didn't you read what I said it's we've
become weird I know I know it's got to
change
I any chance for a conservative peace
movement well I think that's great yeah
would you I think it can happen I mean
the Tea Party was a peaceful movement
but it wasn't about peace it was about
economics but I think at this I think
it's possible but what's this thing
gonna be like the peace movement of the
60s had tie-dye t-shirts and these
what's a conservative light khakis yeah
yeah it's gonna be